il y a 10 ans l'entreprise cararmat
permettait l'implantation du tout
premier cœur artificiel au monde
aujourd'hui la technologie conçue à Bois
d'Arcy a permis d'équiper une
cinquantaine de patients l'objectif de
renavant augmenter la production et la
commercialisation pour répondre à la
crise de l'insuffisance cardiaque liée
au manque de greffon aujourd'hui on est
à peu près sur une augmentation de
d'année en année de l'ordre de on double
notre production d'année en année c'est
un peu l'objectif qu'on a en terme
d'ordre d'idée alors ça varie évidemment
par rapport à la demande hein puisque on
est on s'aligne aussi sur la demande
c'estàd qu'on est capable d'accélérer
éventuellement si on le souhaite c'est
c'est clairement lié aux éthiques
commerciales et à leurs besoins déjà
présent en Allemagne et en Italie les
cœur karmat devrait se développer en
France et aux États-Unis d'ici 2027
notre objectif c'est les États-Unis on
se prépare donc parce que aux États-Unis
on sait que c'est le marché majeur de la
cardiologie mondiale dans tous les
domaines de la cardiologie de ce fait là
il faut que nous on soit prêt et c'est
ce qu'on fait leader dans cette
technologie après plus de 10 ans de
développement et de recherche dans ces
usines la technologie est en constant
développement sur le site de Bois d'Arcy
où sont assemblés les cœurs artificiels
on arrive à un moment où la prothèse a
beaucoup progressé en fiabilité
globalement on arrive sur quelque chose
extrêmement pointu c'est sans doute ce
qu'on appelle le device ou le système
médical le plus pointu qui existe au
monde pu puisque ça ne tolère aucune
défaillance puisque c'est le cœur et
vous savez que sil y a une défaillance
malheureusement ça se passe mal
l'ouverture au marché internationaux est
aujourd'hui nécessaire à l'entreprise
pour atteindre son équilibre financier
cette année le site devrait réaliser une
centaine d'implantations